- Hey everybody, this is Charles Warner
with Innovation and Tech Today,
and we are here with the
great Gary Vaynerchuk.
How are you?
- I'm well, thank you.
- Okay, so, we're just
gonna jump right into this.
We wanna take our readers
kind of a little bit
behind the scenes and--
- Sure.
- You know, let 'em see
a side of Gary maybe.
Tell us kind of how a
typical day starts for you.
You know, a busy guy, you're
doing a lot of things.
- I get up at six, maybe
seven if I can sneak it in,
which is always the best.
I'll work out for an hour,
and then, I'll sneak in a couple minutes
with the family, Monday through Friday.
There is no typical day
because I travel 30,
40% of the year, or the weekdays.
So, it could be lots of airports.
This morning I woke up in Denver.
Tomorrow I'm gonna wake up in Chicago.
So, but usually it is
wake up, look at my phone,
make sure nothing's on
fire, 'cause when you're,
what's lonely about entrepreneurship
in CEO land is you're
the last line of defense.
So, I wanna make sure if there's
anything I have to address,
so there's always a little,
a buzzer goes off and then
the sense of anxiety of,
hey, 'cause we have a London
office, we have an LA office.
So, there's always things going on.
Work out, and then basically
from 8:30 until 10:30
I'm in some mix of 80% running VaynerX,
which is the holding company
that owns VaynerMedia.
I'm in the CEO and chairman of VaynerX
and the CEO of VaynerMedia.
There's PureWow and other things
that we own in that world.
And so 80% meetings for that,
new business development,
hiring, HR, operations, just in it--
- Yeah.
- Operating, and probably
20% of brand building
whether it's something
like this, or meeting with,
an influencer, or just meeting a mogul
or an up and coming mogul,
just human interaction.
- Yeah.
- I'm not in my, I don't
even have a laptop anymore.
- Wow.
- So, I only have my phone.
I'm not in work.
I'm in work from strategy
and people execution
and so, I work a good,
hefty 14, 15, 16 hour day
all the time.
- Do you find that on the road
you can actually get more done?
- 100%.
- Yeah.
- Yesterday I finally did my email.
(laughing)
Because I got lucky.
The WiFi wasn't working
when we first got on
the plane super well and
so I just got into a rhythm
and didn't get distracted and
cleaned up my inbox real well,
which is my to do list.
So that always feel better.
- Doesn't that feel great?
- Oh my God, my admins were thrilled.
(laughing)
And yeah, no question.
The airplane is
disproportionately the place
where I get the most tangible
answering questions of me
making decisions that
are sitting in my inbox.
- Yeah, well, you're kind
of, you're isolated right?
You're there, you're in a
tube, you're going, you know,
500 miles an hour.
You might as well get some stuff done.
- I mean, when it was
pre internet on planes
I really crushed.
Offline, boom.
With the internet, you know,
you can get distracted.
You can get into a Twitter hole.
- Yeah.
- You can get into looking up something.
You can get caught.
- Okay, so tell us a little bit about,
you were an early investor
in Bitcoin, weren't you?
- Good homework.
- Yeah.
- Nothing crazy.
Let's not excited here, but I
did buy some Bitcoin in 2014.
So I was curious about crypto.
I bought some Ethereum.
I made some bucks, but I
didn't put it in real money.
So it's nothing that, I'm not
gonna buy the Jets just yet.
(laughing)
Maybe the Steelers.
- Yeah.
- It's a joke.
A good friend of mine who has
worked with me for five years
who lives out here just walked in.
He's a Steelers fan, so,
just for everybody wondering.
Yes, I thought cryptocurrency
was gonna be real in 2014--
- You still bullish on it?
- I'm unbelievably bullish
on blockchain technology.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if Bitcoin
or some of the other coins
are going to be the currency that wins.
But this would be like
somebody saying to me
do you believe in the internet?
Yes.
Do you believe in Ask Jeeves?
Maybe.
Do you believe in Netscape Navigator?
Do you believe in Google?
Maybe.
So, the winners on top of
blockchain is a little murky.
Obviously Bitcoin's out and about.
But I'm bullish on blockchain.
- Yeah.
- Tremendously.
- Yeah, they say blockchain
has ramifications that can
across all sectors really
just change the game,
kind of open source, and--
- Oh!
- Yeah.
- It is a, the internet
was a decentralization
of a lot of things, but it
was still a centralized place,
which is why you've seen
big companies built on it.
Blockchain goes to a
totally different place.
I think it brings
reputation and who you are
and brand to a whole new
level, and so I'm very excited
to see how it plays out over
the next two to three decades.
- Yeah, yeah.
And that also kind of
segues into cybersecurity.
It's a big thing nowadays as far as--
- Yup.
- How secure is our information.
- What's going on
behind the scenes on the internet.
What are your thoughts kind
of on the state of the state
with regard to cybersecurity and you know?
- I think it's bigger than
people realize, meaning
I think this is more
about being a good person
than about security, meaning I think that
most people actually
don't care about privacy.
You think you do, but
I don't think you do,
because your actions show that you don't.
Meaning, we care about
the health and well being
of ourselves and our loved ones,
and we care about our money, right?
And as long as those
things aren't compromised,
now, if the 15 biggest
celebrities are murdered tomorrow
because they gave away their
location I have a funny feeling
privacy is gonna start mattering.
If your money was stolen
by a scam on the internet
and you couldn't get it back,
Chase bank or Wells Fargo's
like, sorry, tough luck.
- Yeah.
- I think you're gonna start caring
about your credit card number.
But since those two things
are not gonna happen--
- Yeah.
- And maybe there will
be an unfortunate event
with a celebrity, but in the
macro it's not gonna happen.
I think what you're gonna see
is something completely different.
I think all of us are
gonna start acting in a way
that we realize people could see this.
Does that make us, does that
stop us from texting dumb shit?
No.
Does that stop people
from sending nude photos?
No.
We're still gonna be us.
But I think we're gonna
start being more empathetic
and less hypocritical of each other--
- Yeah.
- As we start all realizing
that we're all flawed.
So I have a very different
point of view on this.
I don't see this as terrible.
I see this as phenomenal.
I see that transparency is
the gateway to happiness
and I'm extremely
bullish of the human race
over the next 100 years.
- Yeah, and you actually
think that we're living
in the best time ever right now?
- 'Cause we are.
- Yeah.
- People are healthier.
We're happier, we're richer.
There's more abundance.
Is there genocide?
Yes.
Is there racism?
Sexism, yes.
Crooks, yes.
Just less.
- Yeah.
- And so, propaganda on
television tells us it's bad.
It's just not being backed up by the data.
- Yeah.
- Go ask all your most
bad ass professional women
about their jobs and careers,
and then go talk to
their great grandmothers.
Just tell me who had it worse.
So, you know?
- Yeah.
- Go talk to people that, you know,
both my grandfathers
spent a decade in jail
for being Jewish in eastern Europe.
- Wow.
- Yes, there's bad things going on.
Just not as, you know,
the Black Plague is scary.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- We don't context it.
- I mean, women just
got the right to vote,
it was like 100 and some
odd years ago, yeah.
- Not 100 some odd, 19, oh, yeah, yeah,
you're right, yeah, yes.
But you know, but what about, what, yeah.
But 1960, go look at America in 1962.
A lot to be left desired,
let's put it that way.
And so, yes, do we have dumb shit?
Yes.
Is there a lot of stuff going on?
Is nationalism going across the globe
and democracies are looking
a little bit different?
Absolutely, and so you
gotta keep an eye on it.
You can't take your ball off.
But I just think the world's better.
And the internet--
- Yeah.
- Doesn't care that you crossed the border
and started a business.
The internet is fuckin' the best.
- Yeah.
- My point of view.
- I can't even imagine
the people that grew up
that didn't have, you
know, like how we grew up.
We didn't have the internet--
- We were 18!
- Yeah, yeah.
- We lived our whole--
- No cell phone in high school.
- If you wanted to meet
your buddy after school
you met at the big tree around 3:30
and if your buddy's mom got held up
and he was 15 minutes late,
you quit after 12 minutes,
you missed each other.
People don't, these
youngsters don't get it.
- Yeah.
- I'm just, I'm unbelievably struggling
with people complaining.
I keep bringing up this one example
'cause I saw it happen and it just hit me.
People literally are
complaining about the wrong milk
being put in their $6 coffee.
I mean, if that's your
life, you fuckin' won.
- Yeah.
Yeah, first world problems.
- Not even.
- Yeah.
- $6 coffee.
- Let's talk about your book.
- Yeah.
- I listened to it on Audible.
- Thank you.
- And first of all I love
listening to books on,
I think that Audible, I
mean, it's kind of like
podcasts before podcasts, right?
- Yeah, audiobooks are rad.
- Yeah, and you get to listen
to the person who wrote it
speaking it, which is pretty awesome.
- At its best.
- Yeah.
- Too many authors aren't
reading their book.
- Yeah, yeah.
So, I mean, what's the feedback been?
How's it going?
- Oh, all time, it's the
greatest audiobook of all time.
- Yeah.
- Download it today.
(laughing)
I think people love when I go off script.
I love the opportunity of
updating my own content
that's super fresh with
even more fresh content.
- Yeah.
- I hate doing it.
Sitting in a booth, reading
for four, five hours,
is like torture.
I'm not a good reader.
I've gotten better probably
'cause of the audiobook.
It's unbelievably difficult
to get through for me,
which is rare, 'cause I don't do
a lot of things I don't like doing.
But it feels so good when it's out
and I know that it brings a lot of value.
- It brings a tremendous amount of value
and I think that for someone like you
that's gotta be the most fulfilling part,
is that you're really
bringing value to people.
I see what people write on social media
in the comments and stuff.
That's gotta feel good.
- Positive reinforcement's incredible.
I hate when people are like,
oh, I love doing for others,
and they try to position
it as this altruistic
they're Gandhi shit.
That's fine, and I like it too.
It's a nice feeling.
It's an incredible legacy.
- Yeah.
- But no question I get an
adrenaline rush or euphoria,
whatever the hell it is,
you know, I failed science.
Whatever I'm getting from the
feedback, it's incredible.
It's an incredibly
humbling, prideful feeling
to have people say nice things
and think that you brought them value.
- Yeah, yeah.
Tony Robbins talks about that contribution
and that growth, you
know, the two spiritual
kind of needs that we
have, and when you help
other people you get both of them.
- It's karma, man.
- Yeah.
- Karma's practical.
There is no formula that
isn't more obvious to me
than doing the right
thing is the right thing.
It will work itself out.
Now, the reason people struggle
with doing the right thing
is 'cause they do the
right thing with the intent
of getting something back.
They give with purpose of something else.
- Yeah.
- So they're actually
not giving.
When you're actually just giving
you're giving without expectation.
- Right.
- When people are like, no, it's not good,
it's because they gave with the intent
of then that person reciprocating
something greater than they gave.
Gary V, I'll drive you to the,
I'll pick you up, I'll be a great, Gary,
I'll be a great guy, I'll
pick you up at the airport
and drive you to the hotel.
I'm like, so I have to be
on for those 27 minutes
and answer all your burning
desirable questions one on one?
Now, I'm flattered.
- Yeah.
- But don't position it, if
you said, can you do me a favor
and let me pick you up--
- Yeah.
- And answer 27, that's actually
how you get me to do it.
- Yeah.
- If somebody emailed me
instead of the bullshit of
I'm gonna do you a favor,
I'm gonna buy you lunch,
or drive you to the
airport, and they said, hey,
can you do me a favor?
I'll pick you up in the airport
and take you to the hotel
and can you answer 14
questions, then I would say
that's authentic, I'm in.
- Yeah.
I think somebody pretty
smart said bring value,
bring value, bring value, then ask.
- And thank you for saying that,
and ask is the key,
'cause I think most people
even the ones that bought
into me and like me
and kind of read Jab, Jab,
Jab, Right Hook and got there
thought it meant bring value,
bring value, bring value,
and then take something back.
You have to understand
that the second you start
creating expectations
you become vulnerable.
- Yeah.
That makes sense.
So tell us about K-Swiss.
- K-Swiss, so, I got a random
email almost two years ago
that said I'm the president of K-Swiss
and we'd like to made a Gary V sneaker.
I liked that email.
(laughing)
And I was curious if he was real.
- Yeah.
- Meaning,
I didn't think he was a joke.
I knew he was the actual president.
I was worried that it was gonna
be like an influencer thing.
There was a sneaker that they already made
and I could be like Gary V says.
I was like fuck that.
- Just slap your face on it.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- No, slap my face is
what I was looking for.
I wanted to put my signature
and have a Gary V sneaker
and this isn't one.
This is just a different thing.
But I, there was two
things that mattered to me.
One, I thought it was cool.
I thought if I could
make a successful sneaker
then I'd be the first
entrepreneur for the mainstream.
I wanna buy nostalgic brands in my career.
K-Swiss was a nostalgic brand,
and I also liked that
it could have failed.
I liked the fear of
falling on my face with it.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I thought that was a good energy
and I liked the idea of
giving my friends ammo
to make fun of me.
Literally one of the
reasons I signed the deal
is I romanticized this
vision 28 years from now--
- Yeah.
- Where my friends are like,
hey, remember when you were a dick
and you thought you could sell sneakers?
You idiot!
(laughing)
I think that's a good idea
to always push yourself
where the down side is you
can make fun yourself--
- Yeah.
- And move on.
That's how that deal felt.
It went really, really well.
We have the one coming
out, the 003 in July.
It's gonna be a challenge.
We made a lot of pairs.
Me and the team were kind of looking it.
It's gonna take work, but I
think it's gonna be successful.
- Yeah, did you get any
advice from Daymond John?
- I didn't.
- Okay.
- Though Daymond's awesome.
- Yeah.
- First of all, I tend not to take advice
because I think it's ego.
- Yeah.
- But I've got to figure, or,
but I also think it's slow.
I don't like it, I like taking
advice from the audience.
I'd much rather read every
single person's comment
to this interview than take
advice from somebody fancy.
- Yeah.
- I really mean that.
I really mean that.
And then, by the way, that's how I learn.
I spew advice all day.
If you get value from it, amazing.
If you don't, I love when people are like,
hey bro, sorry, but I
don't watch your stuff.
I'm like, great.
I wouldn't watch it either.
(laughing)
- What do you think is one of
the biggest misconceptions about you?
Speaking of the public.
- I think at first, for all
the people in the audience
just now, who never heard
of me, who are here to see
Tony Robbins and I'm on
the thing, it's very easy
in public settings, interviews--
- Yeah.
- And on stage for my competitive
bravado to be my lead.
- Yeah.
- Steve, for example, let's
use him in this interview,
he knows me, he knows the
part, 'cause he watched
Vayner being built and he
knows how I've handled him,
he knows the far more
compassionate, kind (mumbles),
the warm and fuzzy mama type of me.
I'm a very interesting contradiction.
I am super kind of emotional, soft, not,
because I'm not financially driven--
- Yeah.
- I don't have that cut throat
I'm making a money decision.
Sorry, man, it's just business.
I'll drag out firing someone.
I'll try to put them on.
I'm always there for them.
So, I think the biggest
misconception is that
between my cursing, my Jersey energy,
and my bravado, that I'm cut throat,
I'm winner take all, I'm fuck you,
and I think that there's a
part of me that's like that,
the one that's, when, you
know who I think I am?
I think I'm that athlete
that on the field will
trip you, will hold on every
play, will fuckin' cheat.
- Poke your eyes out.
- Yeah, poke your eye.
But, when the game's over--
- Yeah.
- I'm the first one to
come and high five you,
ask you about how's Karen,
put in a recommendation
for your grand kid to get,
your kid to get into
the school I went into,
if I'm a good player from Ohio State.
I think when I'm on the field
I want to destroy your face
but in real life I want you to have
the happiest life of all time.
- Yeah, empathy.
- Empathy.
- Yeah, just a couple
more questions for you.
What do you think about
the investment side
of the cannabis business?
- I'm very bullish on it.
- Are you?
- Yes.
- You think it's gonna continue to be,
I mean, they're saying
like 20 billion dollars
in the next couple of years, yeah.
- Here's the problem.
There'll be a couple Philip Morrises.
And then there's gonna be
a trillion shitty Morrises.
The amount of money that's
about to be lost in mainstream
cannabis is gonna be as
much as is gonna be made.
People don't understand gold rushes.
Not everybody finds gold.
- Yeah.
- There's a lot of hucksters in it.
By the nature of the
product, you've got a bunch
of fuckin' people in it
that don't wanna work.
- Yeah.
- Really.
You got a bunch of people
that think it's a gold rush.
It's easy, it's free money.
There's no such thing.
- Yeah.
- So, I'm very bullish
on it, just like I was
very bullish on the internet.
A lot of people have made a lot of money
and way more lost a lot of money.
That's what's gonna happen to cannabis.
- Yeah, what about e-sports?
- Obsessed.
- Yeah.
- I think e-sports easily is
a top four sport in America
in seven years.
- Wow.
- Soon, rapid, and at scale.
I think American football,
even with concussions,
American football,
basketball, soccer, e-sports.
E-sports is way bigger than hockey
and golf and other things.
- It's crazy, I mean, we
were just talking about it.
They filled this arena,
like 20,000 people,
for Dream Hack here just
to watch them play games.
- Oh yeah, in Korea 100,000 people.
Look at Ninja, 600,000
people concurrent streams.
This is real life shit.
- Yeah.
Yeah, it's happening right now.
Just real quickly, talk
about some of the advantages
of podcasting as a way to communicate,
and then also you're
really big on voice, right?
- I am.
Podcasting is audio and audio is passive
and audio is convenient
and we love convenience
and there's a lot of people
who now listen to my podcast
instead of watching my
videos 'cause it's easier
while you're running
or while you're driving
or while you're on a plane,
because you have to give
the attention to the screen.
I'm a very, very big fan of audio
and I think we saw pictures
and videos have their day
and will always have their day
but have done incredibly well
in the last seven years on the internet.
I think you're gonna see
audio have an incredible,
we're seeing it, and more,
and to your point about voice,
AI, machine learning, intelligence,
speaking to Alexa, speaking
to Google Assistant,
these are gonna be
incredible technologies.
Voice is the next platform.
- So easy.
- No friction.
- Yeah, I mean, how
could it get any easier
unless you just think about it.
- Think about this.
For Steve to be here he's probably
talked to somebody on my team.
The fact that Steve could
have said in six years,
Alexa, I wanna see Gary
when he's in Denver.
Alexa's like, cool,
let me get back to you.
On my end Alexa's like,
hey, Steve Campbell wants
to see you, you cool with that?
I'm like, yes.
Alexa then or Google then taps
into both of our calendars,
sees when the timing's
right, and books it for us,
and by the way, it might
have been that we shouldn't
see each other in Denver.
We happen to both be in San
Francisco in four days from now
and we both have an hour.
People don't get it.
People don't understand how
aggressive the technology
advances are gonna be.
- Yeah.
Well--
- Hey, I just wanna keep painting,
'cause I want people to hear this.
Alexa, what's the
favorite restaurant of all
my favorite people right now in Texas?
Answer, answer.
No Google search, no going to Yelp,
no posting on Twitter to get answers.
- Yeah.
- Answer,
on the spot, in demand,
real time, clean data, real.
- Yeah.
- Fast!
On the spot.
- Typing's slow compared to that.
- That's the point.
- Yeah.
- Typing's faster to making a phone call.
That's why we text and don't call.
But voice is way faster than search.
Search is in deep shit.
I would not want my life to
be dependent on Google search.
Google search is going to decline
over the next two decades very quickly.
- Wow.
- It will, slow and steady.
Look at your kids, or kids in your world.
Go look at a seven year old.
They're not typing search,
they're voicing search.
They're Alexa and Siri
and using their iPad.
- Yeah.
- Voice.
25% of all Google searches on
mobile devices are voice, 25%.
- Wow.
- Staggering, and it hasn't even started.
- Yeah.
- It's gonna be the whole market.
I'm bullish of voice, and I'm excited.
In six years when it's
completely dominating
people are gonna look back
at all the content I made
during this time and say, wow, he's right.
- Do you have some of
that home automation stuff
where you talk to it, and it--
- Yeah.
- Does your lights--
- Turn on your lights.
- Your TV.
- It's incredible.
- Yeah, it really is.
It's like stuff from The Jetsons.
- Yup, we're here.
- Yeah, we are here.
- We're here.
- So, last question for you,
what advice would you give
for entrepreneurs that wanna get into the,
wanna get into the game?
That wanna jump in there.
There's a lot of people
out there with ideas.
The entrepreneurial spirit's strong.
You're their spirit animal.
What advice would you give for 'em?
- Please make sure if
I'm your spirit animal
or anybody else you think
is cool, and I know a lot
of you think a lot of
different people are cool,
make sure you understand
that those people usually
deployed a lot of self awareness.
They knew who they were.
Zucks knew who he was, right?
Sheryl Sandberg knew who she was.
I knew who I was.
Forget about anything that I've done.
I understood who I was.
I wasn't gonna build an app
or a venture capital fund
when everybody wanted me in 2009.
Know who you are.
Self awareness.
It's cute that you're
sitting in class right now
thinking you're gonna build the next Uber,
but do you have that ability?
Know who you are.
Get in the game and put
yourself in a position
to be successful based
on what you're good at,
what you're passionate about.
The delta of what are you good at
and what are you passionate about,
if you're one of the great
lucky fortunate people
that what you love is what you're great at
you're gonna have some
crazy things happen.
Try to get as close to that as possible.
Don't do something you hate
for the most amount of money
and don't do something so
not practical that you love
that you have to sleep in a cardboard box.
These are important conversations.
Find that delta.
But I think way too many people
are making an extra 30,000--
- Yeah.
- But hate what they're
doing, but they've built
a lifestyle around the
30,000, so they literally hate
their life to have an extra
bedroom in their house,
that they don't use.
- To what end?
Yeah.
- I mean, it's crazy.
- Gary, thank you so much--
- Thank you.
- For taking the time with us.
We really appreciate it, and--
- See you soon.
- See you soon, thanks.
(upbeat music)